le préfet de martinique dans son enquête
dit ce matin quelques jours après la
venue d'emmanuel macro amphi bonjour
forco bin non jeu vont jouer à tous les
auditeurs
le président de la république s'était
exprimé depuis la guadeloupe notamment
sur cette problématique des sargasses un
séminaire se tient aujourd'hui un fort
de france ou faire dernier point sur ce
fléau les conséquences sur le plan
environnemental sanitaire économique
on se souvient qu emmanuel lacroix vers
affirmé que le meilleur remède
aujourd'hui c'est le ramassage dans les
48 heures des algues échouées
est ce que c'est vraiment possible
franck robine oui c'est possible vous
savez en martinique à 53 points de
ramassage 31 sont vraiment identifié
comme des points qu'on vote qualifié de
plutôt facile par exemple les brigades
d'insertion brigades vertes peuvent
ramasser dans les 48 heures et après il
faut reconnaître qu'il ya d'autres
endroits où c'est beaucoup plus
difficile par et comme par exemple les
codes du robert les codes du françois
et là on privilégie d'autres réponses
notamment celle des barrages et tout
sera effectif tout sera efficace dans un
premier temps est ce qu'on a
suffisamment d'argent suffisamment de
bras suffisamment de machines alors
question argent vous savez qu'on a déjà
consacré en martinique 4,7 millions
d'euros au ramassage donc c'est
considérable y compris les crédits
d'insertion le président de la
république vient d'annoncer de confirmer
un plan d'équipement pour les communes
de 5 millions d'euros et nous allons
solliciter la collectivité suffisant la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
nous allons solliciter les fonds
européens pour monter à 10 millions
d'euros
je pense qu'on aura comment comment peut
on qualifier ça de la force de frappe
nécessaire effectivement pour organiser
le ramassage se sera évolué à évaluer
les assurances joueront le jeu beaucoup
plus vite par exemple pour le pour le
remboursement de l'électroménager abîmés
par des sargasses alors c'est un sujet
effectivement qui est techniquement
difficile vous savez que l'état de
catastrophe naturelle qui était demandée
ne peut pas être déclaré parce que il
faut que le phénomène est une fin
malheureusement et que les sargasses ça
revient de façon récurrente
donc on ya un travail en cours et
d'ailleurs le président de la fédération
française des assurances accompagné le
président de la
public en guadeloupe et à saint-martin
pour faire ce travail est effectivement
accélérer les possibilités de
remboursement la coopération régionale
il en sera question aujourd'hui à
l'occasion de ce séminaire mais pour
faire quoi c'est pour savoir comment
chacun réagit à ce fléau dans sociaux
son territoire il s'agira par exemple de
dire nous avons unanimement comme eux
c'est des sargasses provoquée par un
autre état le brésil par exemple
alors il ya un peu de ça en fait il ya
deux directions il ya l'idée d'avoir une
initiative commune qui a été d'ailleurs
lancée elle s'appelle l'initiative
caraïbes et le président de la
république en a parlé à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu à new york
juste avant de venir en martinique donc
il ya l'idée de d'exprimer un
mécontentement collectif alors il s'agit
pas d'accuser le brésil ou les pays
d'ailleurs du golfe de guinée
il s'agit de les sensibiliser de voir
comment ensemble on peut définir des
réponses scientifiques pour minorer les
productions de sargasses la santé encore
franck robine la santé avec cette fois
ci la molécule de chlore des connards
l'état qui a reconnu sa responsabilité
en fait l'état tant qu'ils évoquent des
indemnisations n'en parlera d un
président qui parle de transparence
premières questions très simples
concernant la chlordécone est ce qu'il y
aura une cartographie des terres
polluées publiée très vite ici en
martinique accessible à tout le monde
partout de la réponse et vous la
connaissez depuis le mois d'avril la
cartographie d'ores et déjà disponible
elle n'est pas complète
elle représente 37% des terres agricoles
utiles et ce qu'a annoncé président la
république c'est que nous allons la
compléter je pense d'ici deux à trois
ans gagner à voir si 100% qu'ils soient
réticentes parce que par exemple le
président de la chambre d'agriculture
qui dit ce serait la publication d'une
qualif plainte serait monté certains
agriculteurs contre d'autres le
président la république il a fixé je
pense un cap historique c'est d'emmener
toute la société vers le zéro
chlordécone dans l'alimentation
c'est extrêmement important il faut le
faire de façon collective il faut le
faire en accompagnant les agriculteurs
ont leur permettant d'évoluer sur leur
production leur permettant de produire
différemment c'est ça qui est
extrêmement important et finalement la
question c'est est ce que nous voulons
bâtir ensemble
à venir qui est historique c'est y ait
vraiment une opportunité
et est ce que nous voulons ensemble
travailler vers le zéro chlordécone dans
la limite de ce qu'on veut surtout ce
matin aujourd'hui franck robine t de la
transparence moi j'ai envie d'aller au
marché et d'avoir l'assurance que par
exemple la personne à qui je m'adresse
me disent que cette production biais de
telle portion de territoire et que ce
territoire n'est pas pollué par la cour
d'école
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est un d
autre mot clé de l'annnonce du président
la république c'est la transparence
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
cartographie va être complétée ça c'est
extrêmement important
et puis les 16 17 et 18 octobre dans
quelques jours nous aurons un colloque
scientifique de très haut niveau très
très haut niveau qui permettra d'établir
ce qu'on appelle les consensus
scientifique en matière de chlordécone
voir où en est la science en matière de
chlordécone et il y aura une restitution
de tous les travaux de tous les travaux
sans exception à la population
martiniquaise aux martiniquais aux
martiniquaise pour justement que cette
transparence soient absolus la
transparence et c'est aussi la
traçabilité
comment pourrais-je être sûr que la
banane que la pastèque que le giro mots
que le mango que j'achète tel ou tel
endroit proviennent bien de telle ou
telle territoire alors il ya deux
réponses du racing barre sur chaque
fruit
il ya deux réponses possibles il ya
effectivement les nouvelles technologies
le parc naturel de martinique a
développé vous savez la technologie du
glauque chaîne pour justement identifier
les produits moi j'avais dit toujours au
moins d'avril que j'étais ou lever à la
garantie de transparence garanties de
transparence wallace et ça permet
d'avoir les informations sur le sur le
produit et moi j'avais dit que les
services de l'état étaient ouverts à
cette solution là donc nous y nous y
travaillons et puis à les contrôler il
ya le renforcement des contrôles par
exemple je suis conscient que les
martinique et les martiniquaises
attendent davantage de contrôles
notamment sur les produits importés et
le président de la république a aussi
pris une décision
c'est celle d'augmenter les moyens que
je pourrai consacrée au contrôle ce sera
à partir de quand le contrôle concernant
ces produits qui rentrent dans d'autres
territoires
alors moi je vais organiser d'ores et
déjà un certain nombre de contrôles en
travaillant un petit peu différemment
et puis
les crédits supplémentaires vont être
déléguées nous allons passer chaque
année de 2 millions à 3 millions d'euros
pour notamment organiser ces contrôles
les indemnisations en a parlé également
à l'occasion de la venue de franck e2
d'emmanuel matheron monsieur robin les
indemnisations qui s'accommode d'emploi
comment pour qui mode opératoire pour
chiffrer les pertes à partir de quand ce
sera un ans 5 ans 10 ans qui paiera ça
fait beaucoup de questions ça fait
beaucoup de questions donc je vais
essayer d'en répondre de façon précise
il a indiqué emmanuel macron qu'il y
avait une responsabilité collective et
que dans cette responsabilité collective
l'état y avait sa part et notamment
aujourd'hui ce que l'on sait c'est que
les travailleurs de la chlordécone c'est
à dire en fait ceux des bananeraies qui
ont été exposés à la chlordécone sont
particulièrement concernés par les
effets possibles et donc il a lancé une
initiative c'est l'ouverture de ce qu'on
appelle le registre des maladies
professionnelles qui permettra à ces
travailleurs de pouvoir être indemnisées
d'avoir une forme de réparation
c'est une réparation pécuniaire ça ne
remplace pas patrick bien évidemment
mais c'est un pas important qui a été
fait dans ce dossier des indemnisations
oui on va payer reconnaît qu on est
responsable on ne on établit pas le lien
direct entre l'utilisation de la
chlordécone et les cancers qui
apparaissent dans les organismes
alors vous avez parlé de transparence il
attend ce marché sa considération ce que
ça fait rire tout le monde ça fait
sourire cette histoire vous avez parlé
de transparence et la transparence ça
consiste à dire que en matière
d'indemnisation on va avancer en même
temps que la science que dit la science
aujourd'hui elle dit que en matière de
chlordécone
on peut mesurer si on en a ou pas dans
le corps humain
on peut indiquer que la chlordécone peut
favoriser l'apparition de certaines
pathologies
mais et je sais que c'est parfois
difficile à entendre
la science n'est pas encore capable dit
pas encore peut-être que ça va évoluer
de démontrer que la chlordécone cause
directement un certain nombre de
pathologies
c'est pour ça qu'on organise la
transparence c'est pour ça que les
travaux des scientifiques vont être
ouverts à ceux qui veulent les écouter
pour que le consensus scientifique soit
disponible en matière de réparation
encore une fois on va avancer en même
temps que la science et au fur et à
mesure que la science dira des choses
précises on pourra avancer dans ce
dossier
concernant toujours l'étape mort de
rouge du manuel macro on a évoqué les
fonds européens les agriculteurs ont
posé le problème
ils se sont plaint des lenteurs des
dossiers des blocages des non réponses
le président de la république avaient
veillé tout cela deux revers de la main
il a dit voyez cela avec l'autorité de
gestion donc la ctm sauf que ça ça n'a
pas suffi aux agriculteurs alors moi je
veux dire vrai dire un certain nombre de
chiffres
si vous le permettez il y à 130 millions
d'euros sur les fonds européen agricole
d'ores et déjà 11% 11% ont été payés
c'est à dire à peu près 14 millions
d'euros pour être très précis 32% un bon
tiers a été programmée et contrairement
l'idée qui parfois annoncé il n'y a pas
de risque de ce qu'on appelle de
dégagement d'office lagarde avoir à
reverser des sommes non dépensées axel
fait son boulot après j'entends bien les
critiques qu'on les agriculteurs
notamment sur les non réponses et sans
doute sur notre sur les délais
l'état n'est pas gestionnaire des fonds
européens mais l'état il est là pour
assister il est là pour conseiller et
donc moi même je prendrais évidemment
les responsabilités et j'inviterai les
uns et les autres autour d'une table
pour voir comment on peut déverrouiller
les choses devenaient de l'état mais une
aide logistique de l'êta encore une fois
nous sommes là pour conseiller pour
faire progresser la collectivité
territoriale de martinique reste la
gestionnaire des fonds européens
merci franck robine d'avoir été ce matin
avec nos
robin préfète de martinique bonne
journée
[Musique]